chasin you did an interview and you
mentioned something to the effect of
I've learned that this industry is very
hard you have a lot of people demanding
a lot of things from you and not
everything is going to go your way no
matter how many hours you put into it do
you still feel this way oh yeah for sure
I think you kind of never stopped
feeling that way even if you do get big
so matter how big you are at the end of
the day you are part of a collaborative
medium and there are a lot of people in
this industry despite but a lot of
people but it's also quite small you
know everybody knows each other so you
know you just got to realize that you're
a part of the process and even as it
even if you're a director is controlling
it all you still got producers to attend
to and you can argue with them for sure
does doesn't mean you have to take
everything lying down the end of the day
you know I think you do have to be a
little Buddhist and be like you know
this is just a part of life and I can't
control everything and you got as much
passion as you have to be and be
involved y also got to distance yourself
from it is too shall pass interesting
like a sins yeah yeah there is in person
how do you do that how do you how do you
care about it but at the same time I
mean I hear that and I think it's very
tough for people whatever pursued it is
to not get so wrapped up even though
that can be their downfall i get it i
mean i haven't fully figured it out and
it takes a long way to go I think you
just you got to be professional on the
one hand you know you can challenge
people and you can definitely break the
rules if you know how to do them in a
way that does not anger people in a way
that's like it I'd say if you break the
rules you gotta break them you and less
like if you're absolutely sure that
someone will be like I really like that
you did that and even I don't know it's
hard especially when you're starting out
and I guess I would just say it's just
not it's about the craft but I think you
just got to realize that it's not about
quote-unquote being good which sounds
counterproductive if you're going to
work hard I think if you try to make
something be good we're trying to make
something happen and then that's well
kill you that's what will hold you back
you know and I think you just got to and
it's got to realize that you're not
ger than life you know like they're like
I said earlier there are other people
and you just have to it they take
chances take risks maybe even break the
rules every now and again but you got to
realize that you you got to humble
yourself you know and realize that you
are not everything and that you're not
entitled to anything unless you do good
work and even if you do could do good
work that doesn't mean you're entitled
to everything so keeping that thought
that you want something IE a certain
part and let's say you audition and you
almost get it but you don't get it how
do you live with that and you just
realize that's part of it but what do
you take yourself through to do Lau
yourself to kind of feel down and then
come back out yeah well if you almost
get it that means that they like you you
know that means that they saw something
in you so if you almost get it but don't
they're almost certainly going to call
you back for something and you know
maybe just uh in the future just like
give them a little letter to Sir message
if say like I enjoyed coming in for you
and you know I'm just I'm doing this at
the minute if you're doing something
else and you know maybe they'll come and
see you again and yeah just realize that
you got to do this and you know you got
to let them see you act and just going
to move on to the next one keep working
you